we face a common problem but have a
patchwork
of solutions some living under effective
lockdown
while others can still socialize study
and travel
tonight what are we doing right and
wrong and is there a strategy
that can solve this all welcome to
postcode lockdown
a divided nation
well good evening if you're watching
tonight in wales a full fire break
lockdown is coming
your way later this week in northern
ireland you have it already and aren't
allowed to socialize
go to the pub or even to school but
across much of
england millions are still free to do
all those things
the pandemic response across the uk is a
patchwork
depending on your postcode and still
cases
continue to rise tonight we will ask
what impact those measures are having
and what we should do next are we again
late in taking tough action or do we
need a
radically different approach well with
me tonight virtually i have three
experts to help explore
those next steps anders tegnal is sweden
state epidemiologist
he has become famous as the face of its
unique approach
to the pandemic which avoided strict
population-wide lockdowns
professor sir mark walpot was the uk's
chief scientific advisor
from 2013 to 2017 and is currently
a member of the government's sage
advisory group and calypso chalkidoo
is professor of public health at
imperial
college london thank you all so much for
joining us
well from across the united kingdom and
beyond we have a
virtual audience who will share their
ideas
on what we could do next and tell us
what they make of the proposals
they're hearing hello audience
plenty more from them later but first
what about the politicians
and those advising them as we know too
well they don't speak
with one voice these figures
are flashing at us like dashboard
warnings
in a passenger jet and we must
act now it's not possible to be
absolutely certain where somebody
actually picked up the virus we were
missing college
we do a lot of social distancing but
it's really um
frustrating to know not knowing if i'm
safe
greater manchester the liverpool city
region
and lancashire are being set up as the
canaries in the coal mine i'm in two
minds on whether to keep the doors open
or close them this couldn't have come
at a waste time the economy is not going
to grow i have
genuinely concluded that a circuit break
is in the national interest
it just means that there are like large
crowds at 10 o'clock outside the pubs
instead of it being like at
12 o'clock
[Music]
they told us close immediately or take a
thousand pound fine
obviously we still have quite a lot of
members training and i said to the
officers and i'm not asking anybody to
leave
so first tonight then let's remind
ourselves where we
are in england a tier system divides the
country
into tier one two and three in tier one
there is a
10 pm curfew for bars pubs and
restaurants
and gatherings of up to six are allowed
indoors at outside
under the rule of six in tier two areas
then
like london households are banned from
mixing
indoors but the rule of six still
applies to outdoor spaces
in tier three which includes the
liverpool city region
more restrictions are in place including
the closure of pubs
and bars and residents are advised
against travelling
in and out of their area in scotland
restaurants bars and pubs are closed
across the central belt although
nicola sturgeon has been criticized for
not going further in northern ireland
the so-called circuit breaker
does go further with schools closing two
but places of
worship and gyms are allowed to stay
open
and in wales then today's big news the
government there has announced a
fire break lockdown as well as banning
people from crossing
the border into wales from parts of
england with high
case numbers so first time we go to the
audience i want to check with you first
of all
who here knows the measures you are
are you confident about what the advice
is where you live a show of hands if you
will for that
okay most of you some of you not 100
sure
who thinks that those measures are right
for where you are does it feel
appropriate where you live
you're starting to think about it okay
maybe about half of you think it's
appropriate
and perhaps the key question do you
think the uk government is making the
right
or the wrong decisions in trying to
tackle the pandemic
hands up if you think they are making
the right decisions
two or three of you okay that is not
resounding at the moment
that was our audience's view then but
we've also been asking the public with
the cooperation of yougov
what they make of the current situation
this is what they had to say
two-thirds of people then told us they
were scared of the impact
of coronavirus this winter 29
said that they weren't a majority
52 said the uk government is generally
making the wrong decisions
on how to handle coronavirus 26
said their decisions are generally right
and
nearly two-thirds 61 percent of people
told us they don't
trust boris johnson to make the right
decisions over the virus
while 31 said they did trust him and of
all the leaders or levels of government
that we tested only nicola sturgeon
isn't
more mistrusted than trusted to make the
right decisions
43 trust her and as you can see 43
do not so the public our poll suggests
is clearly worried about the pandemic
questions the westminster government's
approach to it but what about our panel
and anders tegnal
sir mark walpot and uh professor calypso
chalkadoo
welcome properly to you anders tegnal
first of all
no paths come without pain every
decision
right now has consequences that is where
we are with this pandemic
but overall do you think the uk
government's approach
right now is the right one
it's very difficult for me to have any
kind of review of the
uk government's decisions i think what
we learned from this
that is that we have a very difficult
disease to work with
and you need to work very much with your
with your local
how it works locally for you how the how
is the context where you are
what are the things you can do and
especially what are the things you're
seeing
how do you adapt your response to the
actual situation
and how do you do that in a reasonably
quick manner without changing
your route too often so mark let's go to
you the tier system
was just supposed to simplify everything
you might say it has led in some levels
to division and acrimony
was this inevitable do you think if
testing shows where the virus is
that we would see a patchwork of
responses
well it's inevitable that in different
parts of the country
there are going to be different levels
and if you look at the aucklands and
shepherds for example there are very
very few cases indeed because people are
naturally
more socially distanced and on this
issue of leadership
it is frankly much easier to be an
advisor than it is to actually be the
leader making the decisions
they're balancing lives and livelihoods
and it's not surprising that people are
upset about what's going on and i think
if you look across europe
where cases are rising in almost every
country
even germany where there are more than 5
000 cases a day at the moment
there are leaders are you know perceived
very similarly
and uh the job of the scientists on
stage is to advise the government on
how to best control the pandemic but
they also
government is obviously also thinking
about the economy
and obviously the danger is that uh the
compromise which is trying to be reached
between the two
doesn't adequately control either
that is the big rob isn't here we'll
come on to more about that in just a
moment but in terms of the concern of
people
professor chulkadoo two-thirds as we saw
there are concerned about this
are they in your view right to be
concerned and do you think
the government has got the balance just
about right
well i think it's a tough call as you've
just heard
but i think people are very much right
to be confused i think so far
the government response itself has been
rather confused
inconsistent despite the best of
intentions and knowing this is a tough
uh virus to deal with but from an
operational standpoint frankly i think
the uk's
response has also been rather poor take
test and trace for example i think
it's really not acceptable that it's not
operating at
the levels that we would like it to be
operating uh in order to be able to
uh consider options other than uh
national
shutdowns national lockdowns as a
solution to managing the virus in the
short term so
there's a cacophony of expert opinion
expert view
uh and even though that's not perhaps
the uh the fault of the government
directly i think it is problematic and i
think people
all of us are rightly confused uh well
let's uh get the view then of our
audience now some of their experiences
of this pandemic let's go first to the
city region at the
center of that row that public row
between central and local government
greater manchester
and karen hill is there uh hello karen
how are you feeling about
life there right now
um it's very difficult at the moment
because
we've just been told today that all our
hospitals are
at full capacity and andy burnham is
refusing to actually lock down
the manchester area and i think if
liverpool can do it
and lancaster can do it i think we
should be doing it
and it's not about political agenda it's
about saving lives
well karen you're still in tier 2 of
course for greater manchester
after those talks today government says
it is still considering
next steps worth remembering that people
in the manchester area
have been living under some form of
stricter coveted restrictions
for more than two months cases in most
of the areas though
are still going up manchester city
centre itself they have an influx of 70
000
students into the city figures there
have fallen but in the nine other
boroughs that make up
greater manchester they are still going
up the figures are for example wigan
28 week on week uh the week ending the
12th of october
bolton 2 28 berry 25
week on week and bolton one of those
areas that saw its first case of a
thousand cases
uh for the week as well so one of those
areas that has certainly been in
lockdown for a long time
uh in derby though 50 miles away people
are still under the lowest tier of
measures and free to socialize within
the rule of six
nadia sela lives in derby hello to nadi
what's your experience then
oh hi anna i'm nadia saleh and i'm a mum
of two from derby
i started out working from home during
the lockdown and homeschooling my
eight-year-old
with a three-year-old who wants to join
in all the time um our favorite school
activity was a homemade sports day in
our gardens i think
thankfully um no one in our household
caught the virus but we did
miss having family over to celebrate eid
with us
um we're still really cautious about the
virus and i think we try our best to
limit any time our children spend
in any shops or anything that isn't
necessary
and personally i've been inspired to
spend more time outdoors and
blog as well um the one thing that my
children have enjoyed
recently is the return of swimming
lessons and after school hobbies
and i think as much as our tier
classification of lockdown allows we'd
keep
we i think we'd keep doing this well
nadia thank you for that certainly
trying to get back to some sort of
normal life possibly within the rules of
social distancing
concern expressed there obviously still
too
about coronavirus and the cases that
we're seeing across the country
including across
europe as well all too easy to focus too
much on just the situation here in the
united kingdom
governments across europe have taken on
the challenge in many different ways
restrictions
as you know are coming in all the time
in italy for example
it held out for so long restrictions
announced yesterday coming in today
giving more power to the regional mayors
belgium too
pubs bars restaurants closed for a month
so let's see how
it's up to impacting people then in one
country in spain
let's say from israel who lives there
and israel are you under some form of
lockdown where you live
yeah yeah we are we are right now yeah
well here in norwegian we are like in a
kind of a
local partial uh lockdown so that uh we
are not allowed to leave uh
this city just unless medical
work reasons also we cannot meet
people we are not living with and yeah
pubs clubs have been closed since august
but bars and restaurants can only
take away food or in the outside areas
or
terrace yeah uh if they have one
actually yeah
and they are not allowed like to save
like more than five people
uh per table and yeah well today
um the active cases here uh the figures
are like
uh finally going down but uh in some
areas such as like uh castilla leon uh
catalunya they are going like the other
way around so
i don't know how it's gonna be like in a
week but we will see yeah
indeed so well at least some better news
for your area israel
in spain there thank you very much
indeed and the experience of so many of
course across europe
as if we needed any more evidence of the
differences between different parts of
the uk in the response to coronavirus
we got it today when the welsh first
minister mark drakeford announced a
fire break lockdown in the country
starting on friday
northern ireland is already in a
four-week circuit breaker lockdown
the question now is whether we need to
adopt tougher measures
right across the uk and adopt a full
national lockdown
even if brief as we head deeper
into winter in a full national lockdown
all pubs restaurants
other hospitality businesses close as
well as schools and universities
people are encouraged to work from home
this could be in the form of a so-called
circuit break so therefore for a short
period of time
or for the longer term like in new
zealand for example
a country praised for locking down early
with strict measures
which has only seen 25 confirmed covid
related deaths
and just over 1800 cases since the start
of the pandemic
the public according to our poll would
back tougher restrictions
we asked whether they would support a
circuit breaker lockdown
where the whole country goes into a
strict lockdown for at least
two weeks two-thirds 67
as you can see said that they would
support it 26
said they would not 8 didn't know
so audience let's hear from you once
again do you agree
with the public in our poll would you
like to see
another lockdown applied not just at
level of devolved nations
regions or cities but right across the
whole of the uk
hands up or thumbs up as i can see there
if you support a circuit break
okay i would say that's probably over
half of you interesting thank you very
much indeed
let's hear then from someone who
advocates a national lockdown
trisha mckinley is in edinburgh trisha
why so
um for me i think it would be incredibly
hard for people
to go through a second national lockdown
but i think there needs to be one for a
minimum of three weeks
i know how difficult people will find
that i know the con impa
the economy is going to suffer
undoubtedly and but i think our
governments need to provide a much more
realistic measure to support and protect
the economy
to protect low-income workers and and
more importantly our wonderful nhs
and we need to be clear on this people
are
dying you know our behaviors are costing
lives
people are so all fair now about
self-isolating about wearing face masks
you know it's it's not happening now and
i have lost friends to this horrendous
pandemic
and i don't want to lose anybody else
trisha i'm really sad to hear that that
is the experience of many people
obviously
supporting a lockdown trisha there even
if it is
unbearably hard and we saw today wales
then
following northern ireland with a time
limited lockdown
and calling it a fire break according to
its first minister
no household mixing working from home
the closure
of non-essential shops and hospitality
businesses
schools though kept open for younger
children anyway we saw in our poll that
the policy has support
across the general public but let's talk
now to a supporter
of that action from wales glenn is in
bridgend
clin a supporter then tell us why
because i think that the local welsh
lockdowns that we have had haven't done
enough
to bring the virus under control it's
unwelcome of course nobody likes it my
wife and i aren't looking forward to
staying apart from family again
and having our church close again but
our local hospitals are struggling again
and i think it needs to be done
i do feel for the businesses which have
to close again it's particularly hard
for them
but i think that if the lockdown were
delayed for the sake of the economy
we'd end up being forced into a much
longer lockdown
when the virus was too far out of
control and that would be even worse
for businesses and jobs so i think the
action should be
sooner and shorter rather than later and
longer and it may even need to be
repeated but that i guess is how we will
live with the virus until we have a
vaccine or some other way
out of it sharp and deep uh glenn that's
how your first minister described it
today thank you very much indeed for
that
so let's speak to our panel and anders
tegnal sir mark walport and professor
calypso charles kadu um so mark i'm
going to start with you
you're on sage sage recommended on the
21st of september
the government should have a circuit
breaker how disappointed are you
that they did not
well look the evidence is now pretty
clear so there are
about 528 people in ventilator beds now
uh after the first wave of the pandemic
there were about 60
and that was the case throughout august
and so it started to rise
um we've got to get on top of this
pandemic and so i think there is a
pretty strong scientific consensus
to control the pandemic we've got to
increase the social distancing because
at the end of the day
this virus jumps from one person to
another and therefore we have to keep
people apart as far as we can
um and tests and traits has already been
mentioned the challenge i think it's
faced all along is that it's been
chasing demand what it's got to do is
get ahead of demand
and the only way
we're going to be able to live with this
virus in the longer term
on top by using very good public health
measures using tests and trace
and really when outbreaks are getting on
top of them quickly
so there are pretty strong scientific
arguments that we are going to have to
reduce it
and the evidence also is that cases are
rising across the country
um and so other parts of the country are
catching up um and we're seeing the
infection
which is was initially mainly in very in
young people
uh now catching up and starting to
infect more and more older people and so
death rates
are rising and are likely to continue to
rise
so we are going to have to stop this and
it does come back to the fact that the
economy may suffer
just as much if we don't professor
chulker do circuit breakers are already
happening
wales for example just today people seem
to support it we saw it with our poll
but the argument goes that it punishes
those areas
are doing well the hairdresser in north
norfolk the restaurant in cornwall will
also be punished by this
are you a supporter of the idea of a
circuit breaker
to buy time is this short lockdown
where we need to be right now
well i wonder if we're being presented
with uh perhaps false choices and and
fairly unbalanced information i think as
sage has also
acknowledged there's very limited
evidence in support
of the effectiveness of lockdowns and
that's quite problematic because we've
been here eight months ago
and we're still in the same situation
not quite knowing what the impact of
of lockdowns actually is certainly a
national lockdown it's a fairly
draconian and absolute measure so if we
do go down that road we must make sure
that
we have a strong evaluation uh wrapped
around that to really
try and understand what the impact is of
what we're doing but all in all i think
lockdowns are not some sort of a magic
panacea solution for preventing death
eradicating the virus
and getting us back to the pre-covered
normal
i think it's quite important to
understand uh
when and why to introduce such a a
solution and i think
i do agree with the what david nabarro
of the world health organization said
earlier today where he
basically said that uh it's a punitive
thing to do to put britain back into the
national lockdown even for two weeks
um and instead really we should
concentrate on
on test trace isolate we should
concentrate on communicating to people
what exactly it is
that we ought to be careful about social
distancing masks
hand washing what the streets have done
communicate treating people as adults
as opposed to introducing those
lockdowns which ultimately will have to
be repeated over and over and over again
they're not a solution they're not going
to get rid of the virus for us
and what we do needs to bear in mind is
that they have a direct cost
on non-covered health on cancer and
mental health and diabetes and
hypertension
is a massive backlog right now in the
nhs and when we talk about
numbers but potentially of prevented
deaths
thanks to a lockdown we must also look
at numbers of debts caused by this type
of
absolute measure and we may still not
know the full figure
collateral damage everyone agreed is is
going to be big that's the problem isn't
it i suppose
uh one man of course who doesn't believe
that a national lockdown is a panacea
is dr tegnell but we read in british
newspapers over the weekend that even
you in sweden
are now considering some form of
restrictions
is that the case and what are you
thinking of
no not really i mean what we are working
with now is that we try to keep
the recommendations restrictions that we
have all the time
keep them in place and keep people
remembering them and that is a struggle
of course
because people even in sweden are
getting tired of this and then we had
said okay
if we have a local problem we'll go in
there with some
extra restrictions definitely not to
lock down what we're talking about then
is
maybe having gatherings slightly smaller
than they are right now they're at 50
now maybe we'll take them down for a
couple of weeks time to even smaller
but maintenance is thinking to people
that they need to go back to the most
important thing like we
we all said in this panel i think and
that's keeping a social distance
and if you can get that into place i
think you're going to be okay
the lockdown might work i think the
evidence is shaky
but it probably stops a little bit for a
while but the problem is what do you do
afterwards
because if you don't have a plan to what
you do afterwards
lockdown is just sort of pushing your
problems ahead
for a couple of weeks so whatever we do
lockdowns will not save us they might
break a very rapid increase of cases for
a short
time but they will not build a long-term
long-term solution so you really need to
have a long-term solution in place at
the same time
if you really are in a position why
which uk might be now that you you need
to break
someone but the long-term uh sustainable
solutions is something you really need
to have in place
but if the virus is out of control and
hospitals are at the stage
where the beginning not to be able to
cope for example the liverpool city
region
which is in our tier three then do you
think a circuit breaker
or some form of strict restriction dr
teknel
is viable i don't know if it's viable
but i understand that's the option you
might you must go for because somehow
you need to
to send a very strong signal to your
population that
now we all need to pull together and we
all need to keep to have this social
distance between us
so that we break all these chains of
transmissions so that
especially the healthcare services can
get back into some kind of control yes
timing is everything um so mark uh
i know you wanted it before is now the
time though
when we begin to see that respiratory
diseases in this country are beginning
to be
the worst they are is there still time
for a circuit breaker
if the national government decided they
should do that
absolutely absolutely but i i mean i
think this is slightly being set up as
there being more difference between the
three of us than perhaps there is
um the short answer is that the the
measures that calypso was talking about
to have long-term control are critical
so you do need to be able to have very
good testing very good case
identification very good isolation
but the problem is that you need to do
it on a manageable number of cases in
the first place
and with more than 17 000 cases a day at
the moment
rising with beds filling up we've got to
get the cases down
and where i do disagree is that the
first lockdown worked extremely well
arguably it was introduced too late but
it did bring the cases right now
um what didn't happen was that they were
held
and so i think the the way forward has
got to be to get the cases
down so that testing and all of the
public health measures
can work properly and then keep the
disease under control
and treat it as a in a much more chronic
state
and that's the issue and and i've been
worth coming back to anders because
there are different cultures in
different countries and uh
sweden is naturally more socially
distant and it has had
with respect ten times the rate of
deaths as norway
okay we're going to come on to sweden
and your experience dr tegnel
in the next part of our program but
you're right it is very interesting to
see how different populations react
in terms of how we move forward with it
as well
not to mention how we managed to to
handle the peak of the pandemic
back in march april well we've been
discussing the current state of the
pandemic response in the uk
and heard the arguments then for a
stricter lockdown or a circuit breaker
right across the country many prominent
people in politics and the media
especially on the right though
argue that current measures go too far
instead they say
we must be much harder nosed about
protecting those
most at risk and allowing others to get
on with their lives
and if we look across the channel into
europe we see at least one country
which has modeled that response
spain certainly isn't one of them though
instead a state of emergency
has been called in madrid people cannot
leave or enter the capital
for non-essential reasons and
restaurants and workplaces
are limited to 50 capacity
in france then a curfew is in place
between
9 p.m and 6 a.m one country though has
taken
a very different approach since the
start there was no mandatory lockdown in
sweden
nearly 6 000 people have died there from
covid19
according to johns hopkins university
that is 58.4
per 100 000 people in comparison
the united states has a rate of 66.5
last month it was announced that
sweden's economy will shrink around 4.6
this year significantly less than many
other
european countries including the uk
well as you know we have the man behind
sweden's response with us tonight anders
tegnel
you certainly made some big decisions
didn't you at the start of this pandemic
were you right on balance
i think we were right in many things and
we did not really
completely understand that some of the
weaknesses especially in the
nursing homes in sweden would have some
such a devastating effect
when this disease was introduced into
them but
we managed to keep our health services
running with a very high quality of care
took care of all the coffee 19 cases
that were always free best for kobe 9
but also took care of the emergency uh
also entering into those systems so it
it worked in those ways
we managed to not
get the cases down as quickly as in
other countries but we got the
continuous uh slowing down of the
the sea spread from april and onwards
with the same measures in place and i
think the most important thing we had a
population behind us i mean in any kind
of poll we had
80 90 of the population said that they
were happy to keep on following our
restrictions and i think that was
very much part of the success but the
nursing homes
turned out to be a huge problem uh after
a month or two
that was remedied to a great extent
and now for the last three or four
months we have had almost no spreading
on nursing homes in spite of having a
spread in society
i think to me that shows that it is
possible to to run our strategy
and to keep our nursing homes safe but
unfortunately in the beginning
many of the nursing homes were not
really prepared to
to take on the challenge that they had
to take on we share your pain on nursing
homes that has been a big lesson hasn't
it i think for very many nations
at the time you said judge me in a year
you've been judged throughout and
in may sweden had one of the highest
death rates per capita in the world
obviously overtaken now by
north and south america how did you feel
then did you feel isolated
did you feel anxious did you feel
concerned for
for your population in sweden
of course we are worried when we see
those those numbers on the other hand we
must
also realize how difficult it is to to
measure mortality
and in sweden we have a very strict way
of measuring them and we do know that we
we collect and we count a lot more cases
than in many
other countries especially in the us and
america's
on the whole so the difference is
probably not as big as it
is seen sometimes but of course we all
time
wondering if we're doing the right
things but we had a very good dialogue
with many of the nursing homes and there
was a lot of understanding of
what the mistakes were that to some
extent were made in those and when they
were rectified
the situation improved very rapidly and
i think that
made the whole thing easier and it also
made the whole thing easier that
really had a support of the population
all through this even
during the difficult times many in
america
hold up sweden as the great example of
what to do
president trump's new coronis advisor
scott atlas says
lockdowns kill people do you agree with
that basic statement
first of all i mean sweden has had the
lockdown i mean we closed down the
society a lot and
i mean you can compare how much we
stopped traveling in sweden and we
stopped traveling in sweden more than
they stopped traveling in our
neighboring countries so you shouldn't
underestimate the kind of lockdown we
put into place
we did it without legal measures to a
great extent but that's a completely
different thing
swedish society stopped a lot i mean we
we think that we diminished our social
contacts but at least 50
we stopped working we stopped going to
work
um in about 30 percent of the cases and
so on so of course there was a lockdown
uh on the other hand i can agree to real
statement to a certain extent
i think we have sometimes been a bit
haste in putting a lot of restrictions
in place without thinking about
the consequences for public health as a
whole and i think that's what we we need
to think a lot more about
in the future so we don't do more harm
than good uh
with putting all more measures into
place and so mark you were nodding there
i know that mobile phone and other data
does actually show that swedes stayed
home
almost more than predicted um at the
time
but do you think a swedish type model
given our denser
populations housing possibly we don't
have such trust in our government so
mark
do you think it would have been possible
here in this country
i frankly think it's very unlikely
the density of people in the uk is far
higher
uh in sweden for example there are a
much higher proportion of people
living in single households um it is
just different and and the answer is the
infection probably came up in
we were all dealt different hands of
cards if i can put it that way in
that you know uk global hub
global hub cities brussels london new
york tended to do badly
we know that there were over 1300
essentially silent introductions of the
virus
at the end of march uh after the half
term then when people brought it back
from france from spain from italy
um it came in in different ways and so
it's been very widely distributed
in a country with a higher density of
people
um and a different culture um
and clearly america is much more
libertarian in outlook but
you know is is my liberty uh to do what
i want
um balanced against my liberty to kill
someone else because i give them the
infection
these are very very difficult arguments
yes and germany certainly felt that
at the start the cases they had were
younger people
who had returned from this ski resorts i
know one ski resort in austria
is said to have shipped it out to 45
different countries so that was a it was
a really big impact
in this country you know uk half term
perhaps brought
many of the cases in and flip so i know
you are concerned about the unintended
consequences of lockdowns uh one
official
figure put it at 75 000 people in this
country who will have unintended
consequences
do you think would you like to see more
of a swedish approach where you
you trust the public perhaps to do to do
their to do the right thing
by uh by all of us
well well trust works both ways i think
uh yeah trust the public but also the
public needs to trust the authorities
and i think unfortunately so far
we've had such a a complex and
conflicting
series of messages that uh has it's
blown public trust completely and that's
really problematic and worrying because
it's not just about
the importance of complying with
government guidance in managing this but
also
in the near future the importance for
instance for getting getting the vaccine
being you know getting vaccinated and if
you don't have the trust of the public
if people are not quite sure why it is
you're saying what you're saying why are
you changing your mind
why this why that then it's very
problematic in getting compliance which
is of course very important
what i would like to see more of is a
quantification
and a discussion of modeled perhaps
obviously as we model
potential coveted deaths of modeled
deaths and the impact of those policy
measures you're taking
on non-covered health
sectors so the impact on cancer the
impact on mental health and we have
a lot of this work is being done
colleagues for instance such as
professor richard sullivan or kings or
professor
simon wesley uh talked about the toll on
mental health and suicides
cancer we're looking at people missing
on their treatments
uh late diagnosis late presentation and
this is the sort of excess mortality
excess deaths that we'll see down the
road young people
uh who will basically lose their lives
because they didn't go to the hospital
because they're worried because of the
lockdown because of the virus because of
the perceptions
and we need to start quantifying this
every time we talk about
modeled forecasts of potentially life
saved
from kovid because of an intervention
especially draconian intervention such
as lockdowns we need to decide in the
same sentence ideally
numbers of model deaths of people if we
were to go down that route
and i think in parallel we need to talk
about the economy it's not a dichotomy
poverty kills and poverty kills the poor
more than the rich
and we need to be able to also have side
of what it means
in terms of unemployment in terms of
losing your schooling your education
in terms of social unrest this creates
pretty much your mortality people
will die early because of recessions
because of poverty and again we need to
look at those figures too
every time every single time before we
consider a change
or an introduction of radical and
absolute
uh policy measures yes and certainly we
had um the figures out for people dying
at home which had gone up
but out of the more than 56 000 excess
deaths for this period
50 000 i think were covered so but as
you say
people are still feeling the effects
there's a delay isn't there definitely
in terms of
undiagnosed conditions well let's hear
now from our audience and what they make
of that argument
that we should like sweden early on
target our restrictions
more on those most vulnerable and loosen
them
on other areas of life so uh audience
if you don't mind let's have a show of
hands whether you would prefer to see
that that the vulnerable restrict
themselves and the rest of people
get on and live their lives what are
your thoughts hands up if you
approve of that okay maybe a quarter of
you slightly less than that actually
support that
uh one of our audience members though
who thinks we need to learn to live with
the virus deji
yemi from dagenham deji hello to you
tell us your view then
uh yes so in my view i think the current
postcode lockdown
is not needed and should be scrapped
ever since the pandemic began
united kingdom has been disunited
in many ways without different
approaches from different regions
and devolved countries this is clearly
not working
if it is we will not be talking about
another lockdown a house that is divided
against
itself cannot and will not stand
we have to learn to live with this virus
and manage this situation as one united
country as best as we can of course
rather than taking or keep taking
people's livelihood
away so as long as we gonna have
a movement of people between these
countries
a local or postcode lockdown will never
work
thank you thank you very much indeed
uh no lockdown united country needs to
learn to live with this
what about our poll then carried out
with yougov suggesting that british
people though are
not in favor of relaxing restrictions
over coronavirus
we asked whether people support relaxing
lockdown measures for younger people
while maintaining rules for older and
more vulnerable
people 26 supported that idea
but the overwhelming majority 64 opposed
it
10 percent didn't know you're nodding
again sir mark the barrington
declaration some might say wanted that
did they not
uh you obviously don't approve of it
would it be dangerous do you think to go
down that route
absolutely in this case the british
public are absolutely right and the
evidence supports them
um and keeping generations apart is
effectively
impossible people live in
multi-generational families
actually particularly people from uh
asian backgrounds from black
backgrounds so you can't keep people
apart
and what we're seeing at the moment is
that whilst it started
uh this uh second wave predominantly in
younger people it is spreading into
older people you simply can't do it
and when it comes to the concept of just
leaving it and letting it rip them we'll
all get hurt immunity
again the evidence is absolutely against
the people that say this is a sensible
thing to do
we know that a relatively small minority
of the population uk have had this virus
so far
and the rest do not want to get it if
they can avoid it
um and also the idea that it just kills
as
it were an elderly uh chronically ill
segmented population we know that those
that recover from the serialness severe
illness can be ill for quite a long time
and we also know that young people
sometimes get
this thing called long cape which is
probably a series of different syndromes
so
even if you apparently get it mildly
it's not benign
um so as i said that that concept is not
supported by
any significant body of scientific
opinion at all
okay so mark thank you very much indeed
more from the panel in just a moment
on postcode lockdown a divided nation
then we've been examining
the options for policymakers to take on
the pandemic
over the winter as we've seen there are
flaws with
both relaxing restrictions and a blanket
new national lockdown
so is there a route which balances
health and wealth
which we can follow well let's go again
to our audience and hear some of their
views on how we can improve
our handling of the pandemic compliance
is critical obviously let's get the
thoughts then of
maria hello
anna good evening um yeah i lost my
mother
to covet 19. i also work for the nhs
and from what i've witnessed i think
we've become a nation that
can't obey rules the government in the
past has suggested
bringing in the armed forces to assist
the police
and it's proven from the discussion
tonight that countries that have a
bigger success with communities adhering
to lockdowns
and partial lockdowns and the
recommended
restrictions such as social distancing
and even simple mask wearing
all of those countries benefit from a
two and three tiered police force
and i think uh well i question is this
something that now needs to happen
in these uk covid hot spots where
clearly
we have huge amounts of people who
are not adhering to anything maria is
positive from
from sorry thank you very much indeed
for that so greater adherence then to
the rules by using possibly
the resources of the police and the
armed services
one of the thorniest issues for the
government during the pandemic
has been how to stop people bringing in
the virus from abroad we already
mentioned didn't we
the resort of ishkel in austria skiing
holidays in the alps back in february
and early march
blamed for seeding many of the cases
which first
broke out in the uk later on obviously
the government bringing
quarantine regulations so how could we
detect
people who are carrying the virus more
easily perhaps without
suspecting it let's hear the idea of
margot ward
who is in devon margot
hello anna why aren't we making use
of man's best friend during this
pandemic
dogs are very easily trained to sniff
out cancers
drugs landmines etc
so why not povid 16
dogs are already employed at helsinki
airport
working shifts in teams of four
the dogs are able to sniff out people
who are asymptomatic
or not yet showing symptoms quicker than
a standard kovi test
our uk medical detection dogs are
already training
six dogs to sniff out covid should we be
training
many teams of dogs to work at
all uk airports to try to lessen
the transmission from overseas thank you
lovely idea thank you margot yes okay
and thank you to the audience for those
thoughts
so technology research science
may of course be the route out of the
pandemic
via a vaccine for example but should we
be holding out for that solution
according to our sky poll the public is
split over whether it will be possible
to tame the virus without one we asked
whether it is possible to solve the
issue
of covid19 before a vaccine is
discovered or if it will
only be possible after a vaccine is in
use
40 percent then said it could be sold
before a vaccine
43 only once it was discovered
17 not sure to our audience again once
again what do you make of that do you
think
we'll have to wait for a vaccine before
we can control
the coronavirus hands up if we should
wait
for a virus for a vaccine rather
one two three four five okay
you seem more optimistic let's speak
then to anders tegnal so mark walpot and
professor calypso thank you very much
indeed for joining us um let's go to you
then professor chulkerdoo
vaccine will that be the great panacea
that we're looking for
well a vaccine is a an absolutely
essential part of
of the response and hopefully we will
have one or more
in a year's time or so now whether it
will be the silver bullet or all hoping
it to be
that's that's questionable perhaps not
the first generation perhaps the second
generation vaccines will be more
effective but
ultimately without a vaccine the virus
will have to
go into a population and reach some form
of population level immunity which will
take a long time
which will be difficult as we've just
been discussing
we need to be maintaining social
distancing
all these measures we've been talking
about so it may well take years until it
becomes endemic if you like and
resurface
every year maybe now this may also
happen with a suboptimal
cov19 vaccine so it's not necessary that
a vaccine
will solve things but really i think
it's quite important
in our toolkit covered vaccine is a
quite important tool
in in tackling this outbreak
and yet uh sir mark we heard from
patrick valence today
suggesting it will be next spring at the
earliest before we see something
um is is that right should we hold out
for it
will it make a difference given the fact
that other coronavis
there are obviously no vaccines for them
well in the sense
that i'm not sure holding out for it is
the the right terminology
we need around the world people are
going as hard as possible
to create vaccines and they're being
tried out um
and uh there is a reasonable chance that
one of these vaccines will prove
uh effective to some degree so we have
to go for that
but i mean that doesn't mean that whilst
we're waiting for that we ignore
everything else as it were
and the other thing is that there are
other approaches so we know much more
about the treatment of this disease
which no one no one
had ever seen before uh until this year
and so oxygen demands in hospitals being
met better people are ventilated better
and we know from very careful clinical
trials the drugs that are
anti-inflammatory such as dexamethasone
can reduce the death rate by up to a
third in people that have that severe
late inflammation that's what kills
people
and we have to do more clinical trials
there are antibodies being tried that
can bind to the virus so
um that's another approach the regeneron
but there are other companies
manufacturing them as well
um and sadly we also know that there are
some drugs that have been tried that
don't appear to work
and so hydroxychloroquine does nothing
and
recently just in the past couple of days
evidence has come out that this
antiviral drug rem deserver
which seems to reduce the number of days
people spend in hospital doesn't appear
to have a significant effect on
mortality
so we need every possible measure
and it's likely that the mortality is
going to be much lower in hospital which
is a good thing or significantly lower
at any rate
we have to do everything we can to get a
vaccine and predicting the future is
extremely difficult we're weighting
uh the results of the trials that are
going on at the moment um
if a vaccine does become and shows
effectiveness
then you know it makes a lot of sense
for people to have it
vaccines have been one of the most
powerful ways of uh controlling
infectious disease you know if you look
at the things that change public and
health and enable populations to live
on average longer it's been clean water
and vaccines that have made the biggest
difference
yes you didn't even mention the
monoclonal antibodies which president
trump declared was his
his cure although he did take rem
deserve as well didn't he um
as as you know um anders tegnal i know
you suggested
right at the start that the vaccine
would take at least a year that's one of
the reasons
you suggested sweden should learn to
live with this the concept of herd
immunity was also central to to your
idea
do you still be believe in that and do
you think sweden has edged close to herd
immunity
we never really believed in her immunity
we talked about that an immunity in a
population
is gonna make some kind of effect but
her immunity is not possible to she
without a really good vaccine
but i think the danger with saying that
we're gonna wait for the vaccine is to
seem to be some kind of
myth about that then we can all go back
to normal i mean it's not going to be
that easy
if we get a good vaccine we might
hopefully be able to protect the
vulnerable part of our population better
if we get a vaccine that works in those
partial population
and that will of course mean that it's
going to be much easier to deal with
this decision today
and if we get some good treatments that
will also improve but
all in all none of these things are
really going to get us
completely rid of this virus we need
also have long-term things in place
that we can live with for a long long
time because this disease is going to be
with us for a long time and to think
that we're going to eradicate it with a
vaccine
i don't think that's going to happen
maybe never but definitely not
withi within the kind of life span most
of our
most of ourselves yes indeed the four
coronavirus that we live with
day in day out are endemic are they not
and we've learned to live with them we
will see what happens with that
certainly
to the audience though if there was a
vaccine available
right now would you take it hands up
that's not quite everybody but i think
it probably is a majority of people
um we're approaching the end of postcode
lockdown a divided country it's a huge
subject matter we've heard about tougher
lockdowns
lighter restrictions and whether
vaccines are the only ultimate way out
what should government do next what
should government do now
let's go to our panel then um okay
dr tegna let's start with you very
quickly if you don't mind what should
the british government do now
i wouldn't dare to advise the british
government but i think it's
you really need to understand what is
the the worst part
where is the disease spread most and
really concentrate your efforts on that
so you don't lock down too many things
because then
the lockdown is going to have a lot of
negative effects there's probably going
to be worse
than the positive effects so i think the
trick is really to try to understand
what are the sort of serious areas you
need to to
to stop the transmission in professor
chalkadoo
you were nodding your head there
targeted lockdowns or targeted
restrictions
you support what's your advice to
government right now then
i think it's really important that
policies refocused
um from just coving 19 and the direct
management of the pandemic to
broader welfare issues we need to think
about
the collateral damage of the policy
interventions of the virus itself
uh if it were left unchecked but also
the policy is introduced
we need to be in a position to talk
about people's livelihoods
education employment cancer diabetes
these are important areas of people's
lives
and we need if we can measure potential
coffee debts we need to be able to
measure
the impact of policies on education on
other types of of health and disease and
unfortunately if we don't do that if the
welfare agenda is left behind
i think we will lose the public i think
would be an even greater
crisis of trust uh and so for the
measures to work
we need to be able to communicate
exactly what the target is and we need
to be able to demonstrate
that perspective is way broader than
just covet however important of it is
it's about
welfare and it's about having social
cohesion being able to survive a society
going forward
i don't mean to interrupt you the last
minute someone willport is yours
you're already a sage advisor this is
your day job what's the message for
government
well the answer is get the infection
under control
get the numbers down across the country
uh emphasize to everyone
that we do need to maintain social
distancing
once the numbers are down make sure we
don't let them go up again by having
very good public health
measures to keep it under control so
test and trace keep working hard
to develop new treatments to improve the
therapy get a vaccine
and at the same time of course we have
to worry about the economy the evidence
is being collected unfortunately
coronavirus is a virus that strikes poor
people
more than richer people um and so uh
all of those points are well made the
nhs and chris whitley the chief medical
officer is saying
is open for business for all diseases
and it's very important that if people
have
an illness which would normally take
them to casualty then that's what they
should do
um and so uh it's not a question of one
thing or another we've got to have a
whole
series of measures and we have got to
take individual and collective
responsibility
to keep this thing under control panel
our audience have been voting
i want you to vote now on a scale of 1
to 10 where 10 is really bad
how concerned are you about the winter
all of you vote at the same time hold up
your fingers for
for a scale of one to ten please
okay
you're not sure is that a five i think
it's a five uh lovely to have you on
thank you so much anders tagnell
sweden state epidemiologist sir mark
walpole sage advisor
former chief scientific advisor and
calypso chulkido professor of public
health
at imperial college london thank you so
much for your time
big thanks to to our audience give
yourselves a round of applause
thank you so much for joining us and
thank you for watching
you